you wake up in the westin wildfire is
exploding across Southern California the
flames look at these flames are racing
into the city of Ventura home to more
than 100,000 people at least 150
structures have already burned thousands
of homes are under mandatory evacuation
orders people rush to escape overnight
the flames destroyed a transmission line
causing power outages to more than
260,000 customers containment is at 0
percent more than 30 thousand acres are
burning northwest of Los Angeles Santa
Ana winds are pushing the flames Jamie
yuccas is in Ventura with more Jamie
good morning good morning
over my shoulder where you see those
flames burning right now that's where a
200 unit apartment building once stood
it is now gone firefighters are trying
to save whatever structure they can in
this fast-moving fire but right now the
flames are at 0% containment thousands
of Californians have left their homes
overnight as flames raced into their
backyard I'm not gonna wait around for
somebody to have to come rescue me so
I'm out of here others weren't as eager
to leave their apartment it's our home
you know see it go you can't panic you
just kind of go with the flow it's it's
just the wind you just don't know where
it's gonna go
winds moving at more than 50 miles per
hour are driving the flames west making
conditions more difficult for first
responders with winds like this fire
growth is just absolutely exponential
Ventura County Fire Chief Mark Lorenzen
says more than 500 firefighters are on
the ground desperately working to gain
the upper hand as far as getting ahead
of the fire that's exactly what we're
doing right now but it's in defense of
structures and property right now not
actually trying to put the fire out you
can see those flames out there power
just went off flames torched a key
transmission line knocking out power for
more than 260,000 customers the only
thing we're seeing right there are
streets all the homes in this area power
is out the tork County Sheriff Jeff Dean
there's a main power line source it runs
along this Ridge and that's what the
fire is burning down
areas aren't really necessarily affected
directly by the fire are being affected
by sporadic power outages as the fire
burns down the power lines a thousand
firefighters battled the flames from the
ground overnight but we just were able
to see the first helicopter dump water
that's because conditions until now were
too dangerous for those helicopters to
go up fire fighters are concerned that
wing conditions could pick up and make
things dangerous today Jamie thank you